hi Mr Knowles my name is Kat and I have
a question and before I State my
question I just want to honor that we
are all standing on the land that
belongs to the Ojibwe anishinabe people
uh thank you for mentioning that I meant
to mention that at the beginning of my
speech but I'm glad Dakota Northern
Cheyenne
um and they have been here for time
immoral and so that leads into my
question so um you make the statement
that transgenderism must be eradicated
from public life entirely and so I'm
going to ask you a question about that
but prior to that I want to just state
that for 5 000 Years BC Gala transcribed
the androgynous trans Priests of
Sumerian goddesses have been around and
noted 200 300 years before Christ in
ancient Greece there were Gods worshiped
by golly priests who wore feminine
attire and identified as women since we
are standing on anishinaabe land turtle
Island which is the nation that we live
under
um
right well maybe you should read a
little more indigenous knowledge books
in indigenous communities have used
two-spirit personas for the entirety of
their culture and so that leads me to my
question when you say that
transgenderism must be eradicated from
public life entirely I ask you Mr
Knowles how can we eradicate something
that has been here as long as humans
have well yeah there have been all sorts
of crazy terrible ideas for a very long
time too you you're pointing to
civilizations that committed Human
Sacrifice okay you're saying that some
ancient Pagan tribe worshiped demons and
therefore we need to castrate children
that's not a good argument yes that's
true there were all sorts of terrible
tribes in fact as recently as a little
over 500 years ago the Aztecs here in
the Western Hemisphere slaughtered 80
000 people in a sacrifice to one of the
demons that they worshiped within the
span of four days that's not a
recommendation of doing that I don't
think that we ought to consider it
though unfortunately in our increasingly
Pagan and liberal culture we do commit
human sacrifice to the tune of 800 000
babies a year sacrifice Feist through
abortion and it would make the Aztecs
blush what we do but but that doesn't
make it the right thing you refer to a
notion that is increasingly popular on
the left which is the idea of the two
spirit among various indigenous tribes
that is not real that is a contrivance
of white liberals in America there have
been various conceptions of sex and
gender for all of human history uh but
but the the idea of the two-spirited uh
indigenous intuition of some Modern
transsexual living in New York City
who's a man who very much desires to be
a woman that is a complete fiction you
will not find that in literature dating
very far back so what does it say about
the question itself the question
regardless of what the ancient Sumerians
believed before they chopped up little
little kids or whatever is is it true
can a man really be a woman and can a
woman really become a man we all know
that the answer to that question is
false that's why Professor McCloskey
pulled out of our debate at the last
moment next week because even a
distinguished Professor but knows he has
the intelligence to know even if he is
transgender identifying himself that he
can't win that debate because the idea
is indefensible so the question becomes
how does how does one know that someone
with the total physical appearance of a
man how can one know that that person
really is a woman do you have an answer
to that question
how can your was to clarify you're
asking how can somebody know if they are
a woman and how can I know if that
person is a woman if if not by the
physical attributes they're natural and
enduring biological sex what's the
alternative to that
so my my response to you is then a
question of what is the purpose of
knowing another person's sexual ideas
let me finish if it's not for the
premise of reproduction
there's no need to relate outside of
that then I don't quite understand why
we would need to question or so this is
what this is what happens whenever you
ask a transgender activist to explain
even the basic premise of the movement
is they'll immediately say well who
cares why why are you so obsessed with
this I'm not obsessed with this I'm not
the one who started sending men into the
women's bathroom and taking away their
trophies and castrating kids I'm
perfectly happy with the way things have
worked for thousands of years it is the
transgender activists who are trying to
upend everything and so I think it's it
is at least my right to ask the question
okay what is the premise of your
movement but they always deflect from
that they always withdraw from the
debate they always try to change the
subject because there is no answer so
you ask me well what's the purpose of
why do you even care what's the purpose
of knowing someone's biological sex well
for starters because we have civil
rights specifically for women in the
United States we have special bathrooms
for women we have special sports leagues
for women we have all sorts of special
places and rights and Privileges and
that are for women that are not for men
so if now some men people who at the
very least appear to be men are claiming
a right to go into those women's
bathrooms then they we either have to
abolish all of the special rights and
privileges that have existed for women
for all of human history and are
enshrined in our law or they need to
explain to me how those men are actually
women and they can't do the latter and
I'm not willing to do the former and I
don't think women across this country
are willing to do the former even if a
few people have been so ideologically
blinded that they that they would give
in to this kind of an absurdity